in communist countries 98
of people did not want the communist
outcome but were too afraid to push back
against the two percent of the crazy
they're afraid to lose something and i
see it in my own life with people that i
know that they know it's all a lie or
they're not willing to push back against
him
james o'keefe welcome to the show
great to be with you
rogan called you the boogeyman you the
boogeyman
um
yes in some respects uh if as uh
journalism is printing what somebody
does not want printed
not being the representative
spokesperson ombudsman for those in
power if you're challenging then i guess
i'm a boogie man depends upon who you're
talking to the fbi stole your phone as
well have you got that back yet
no i have not they took two phones in a
raid against me in november
which is highly unusual because they
didn't take my ipad or my laptop but
they did have a search warrant
signed by a magistrate judge
in the southern district of new york
which is federal court and the federal
judge ordered the fbi to stop going
through my phones and now it's in this
sort of litigation this sort of battle
in court in federal court um and a
special master was assigned people don't
know what that means usually it's a
special
independent uh legal official to oversee
what the fbi is doing and the federal
judge cited journalistic privilege which
is a big win for project veritas but i
haven't been charged with a crime
um i mean we could spend an hour just on
this matter but uh it was absolutely
unconstitutional illegal for for them to
do this to an american journalist
and we're gonna fight it we're going to
fight it all the way what was the story
though
well a source had given or transmitted
me a document ashley biden is the
daughter of president joe biden
her diary
and
i looked into it there were some things
in this diary there were some some some
things she wrote
um including that she had taken showers
inappropriately with her father i didn't
know what that meant
um i did not know if it happened and i
didn't know with a 100 certainty that
the diary belonged to ashley biden i was
almost certain but not totally certain
so i didn't i didn't run the story i i
reached out to joe biden for comment um
i tried looking into it and i'd made the
decision which was very controversial
internally at project veritas to not run
this diary not publish a diary and then
a year later the fed showed up at my
door with a battering ram a search
warrant put me in handcuffs raided my
apartment and took my devices
and the attorney general of the united
states merrick garland expressly forbids
this these execution of these search
warrants against journalists journalists
in the united states are protected by
supreme court law
bar nikki b vapper from 2001
you can publish a document that is
stolen so long as the journalist did not
participate in the theft of that
document think of it using common sense
if you stumble across a document what is
your
you can't be liable for that um but uh
of course we live in a clown world where
uh two plus two equals five to quote
your george orwell the late and great
george orwell from 1984 different laws
apply to different people the u.s
attorneys in new york argued that i'm
not a journalist for the judge their
logic was and i'm not making this up i'm
paraphrasing the prosecutors their
argument was james o'keefe does not get
permission from the people he reports on
your honor and that's why he's not a
journalist which is an argument so
preposterous and so absurd it defies
reason which is why i wrote this book
called american muckraker
what is the line between ashley biden's
diary and the raid how do you know that
it's to do with that particular piece of
information
well because it's said as such in the
in the search warrant i when i after i
was in they put me in handcuffs at first
i thought i was under arrest
um and then some 15 minutes later they
showed me a document that listed crimes
including accessory after the fact
and miss prison of a felony for those of
you who don't know what that means miss
prison of a felony is a very seldom
prosecuted crime in the united states
it's a essentially a bystander law you
see someone else committing a crime and
you did nothing accessory after the fact
includes transporting
stolen documents across state lines
again
this is such an unbelievably
preposterous crime
it would imply that all journalists in
every newsroom
should be incarcerated for emailing
documents given to them improperly
in fact the new york times published my
attorney client privilege documents why
aren't they raided by the fbi for
transporting improperly obtained
documents but this is uh admittedly by
the prosecutors in court regarding
um the ashley biden diary
you already had decided that you weren't
going to publish there was pressure
internally within your camp to maybe try
and get you to do that and you decided
that you weren't so i'm trying to work
out what this raid achieved do you think
it was perhaps an excuse to be able to
get access to your phone so that they
could go through other stuff to try and
see what else you're doing and this was
just fortunate timing
well i don't like to speculate that's
one of my rules in my ethics chapter i
don't like to do that i i can't tell you
who or what or why it was so
i will be a little vulnerable by saying
i was pretty
i had been incarcerated 10 years ago in
another story another book i written uh
in new orleans i was a journalist in a
federal building asking questions and
they shackled me and charged me the
crime so i had a bit of ptsd after this
i i guess you could say i was a little
traumatized by the incident
because it was so
egregious
and i'm very fortunate okay i have a
good team i've got good lawyers i've
survived a lot a lot of things in my
life in fact the first chapter of this
book is called suffering so i don't mean
to sound like i'm whining or i'm
complaining however
when they go after the first amendment
what you know to quote martin luther
king a threat to justice anywhere is a
threat to justice everywhere when they
attack
the first amendment like this
it may be one of the most egregious
things the government can do
and this is a rubicon they've never
crossed before you have to go back to
say the pentagon papers for for for
journalism to be challenged like this
hell i'm not sure the new york times
would publish the pentagon papers
in this paradigm that we find ourselves
in
but it was definitely for me a wake-up
call it was like wow they're gonna cross
this bridge now they're gonna they're
gonna do this
and and i don't know what they're i
guess they thought
i don't know what they thought i was
gonna be intimidated i was intimidated i
would be a sociopath not to be
intimidated whenever they put you
through a federal process with secret
grand juries and fbi raids
it is
hell it is it is a kind of dante's
inferno and um
i guess i i uh what i made the decision
um in lieu of this raid against my
colleagues to make a statement i did
make a public statement
a lot of people
thought that was unwise for someone who
was under federal scrutiny but i know
the truth shall set me free and i
clarified what the facts were and
exactly what the facts were i made a
public facing statement and i continue
to do our journalism i refuse we refuse
to be intimidated
silenced
threatened it's un-american is what and
and the aclu and the reporters committee
came to our defense which shows me that
there's still a venn diagram in this
country of left and right and there
still is an overlap even they
who hate me
thought that this was a bridge too far
for them to cross
people do know
these institutions and the press
organizations and the fbi and whoever it
is that sometimes comes after you they
do know that every time they do that
they just put more eyes on you
i i don't know that they do know that i
i i think the biggest streisand effect
in ever
that's presupposing that someone in my
position can is um
willing to continue
and i write i wrote a chapter in this
book called suffering
and um it's painful man i mean david
deliden a colleague of mine who did the
planned parenthood videos he was raided
by kamala harris's she was now the vice
president but she was then the attorney
general of california had a swat team
took his hard drives
um andy noe colleague friend of mine
thrown cement at him at the portland
rallies
and um i was in shackles in new orleans
i'm talking federal federal not state
they put you in leg chains and they put
you in a leather waist belt and an
orange jumpsuit
and in that moment in space and time i
actually thought my life was over
it's very hard to re to to
bounce back from these sorts of things
you're you're in federal prison
um everyone that you know this is 11
years ago everyone thinks you're done
for you're you're over it's game over
everyone's calling you a criminal a
felon
um you you you have to be a little bit
of a masochist you really have to like
pain
um and
but
what and i said this to michaela when i
met her too it's like when you're
passionate when you
when you believe so much in something
and you have a vision for seeing it
through when you have a vision for
showing people things
that's the most important value to you
and and all these other things are sort
of like
distractions trying to get you off your
game
not easy though certainly not easy and
you certainly have to be built a certain
way to to withstand it how many times
have you been sued now
does dozens
uh we've never lost veritas has never
lost a lawsuit that's something that's
not on our wikipedia page by the way you
can go see
in fact
i'm most proud of the the last year we
sued the new york times for defamation
and we won a historic victory in that
case the judge ruling in new york state
of all places not a friendly
jurisdiction that it was the new york
times that acted with disinformation and
deception towards me people say well
o'keefe how could you be suing them for
defamation aren't you pro first
amendment
well the first amendment doesn't protect
defamation you can't intentionally lie
about a public figure the new york times
versus sullivan case established that in
1964
so the new york times called our videos
deceptive
they weren't
and the new york times admitted in court
documents they got the facts wrong in an
article about me
they have yet to correct the article
thus
actual malice
so oftentimes they accuse me of that
which they're guilty of they'll say i
selectively edit and i deceptively edit
well that's what they do
they'll say i don't ask for comment well
the new york times admitted they didn't
ask anyone for comment in their piece
about me
and we live in this sort of weird
dystopian land where the media
everything that they're guilty of
they throw those accusations against me
and when you go to court of course those
arguments sort of melt away when you're
in cross-examination and depositions
that that rhetoric no longer exists you
are forced to confront the reality and
these cases get dismissed at jury
verdict or in summary judgment yeah you
love a deposition
i love depositions that's your past time
like that's how you spend a sunday
afternoon
nice deposition cup of tea
love it love it i i mean you're not
exaggerating i mean i actually do drink
tea
in the deposition
and people say well why would you like a
deposition
well the reason is this and this is a
chapter called secrecy in this book it
took me 10 years to figure this out what
i'm about to tell you and it's it's so
it's so self-evident i don't know why it
took me this long
secrets
i realized in the last probably
three years about three two or three
years ago i can't keep secrets
the only thing i can keep secret is the
names of our donors and the names of our
whistleblowers
everything else is public
and
they that meaning all the people suing
me keep so many secrets
so in a deposition
i love it because i'm like please do see
my emails you'll see a fairly ethical
organization trying to do the right
thing are we perfect no everyone makes
mistakes i think i've made a few
mistakes in a decade maybe two or three
but they make mistakes all the time and
they try to conceal that so when i enter
discovery and litigation
we're gonna win
because
in a deposition you film the the other
party and you film me and please do film
me i'd like to engage in a conversation
they don't want to have a conversation
they don't want to be asked questions
which is why they stopped suing me
because they quickly realized we're
going to enter discovery and they're
going to lose what are the biggest
mistakes that you've made or what was
the biggest mistake that you've made
over the last 10 years
well there was one there was in 11 years
ago you have to go back to 10 years 11
years ago in an npr investigation there
was a moment
people will continually bring this up i
had covertly filmed the vice president
of fundraising for national public radio
and a restaurant
and he was saying something to the
effect of white people are racist and
gun-toting racist racist people and
there was an editorial edit in that
moment where he was quoting somebody
else and then halfway through the
sentence he starts to characterize
himself
so people say well you deceptively
edited this man i defended the edit but
admittedly i wish that uh i wish that i
had um uh
that that edit was fuller it was a 10
minute recording
i i continued to defend that but people
will bring this up as evidence that i'm
deceptive editing
there was a case in 2012 when i
reported on some documents showing a
voter was a non-citizen it turns out he
was indeed a citizen i was referring to
court documents that were themselves
erroneous
um
and that's a little like oh the pimp
costume
in 2012 people say well you didn't wear
the pimp costume into acorn
now hannah was dressed like a hooker
these are the pimp and hooker videos
but i but i said oh i established myself
as a pimp i said i had hookers and i was
wearing satin tie with a camera in it so
people will use this as evidence i'm a
complete liar and a total fraud and you
can't trust anything i say because in
2009 i did not wear the the huggy bear
costume
into the offices
that's all that i can remember these
three things and eric weinstein and joe
rogue
continuously said everything that
o'keefe does is a lie
but but can you can you tell me why
because we won in court you know every
single case
they say i edit we take them to court
and the judge says nothing was edited
improperly in one case in north carolina
in the shirley teeter case it went to
jury verdict and the federal judge said
looked at the plaintiffs and said if you
sued
mike wallace of 60 minutes
for what you are suing project veritas
for everyone in this courtroom would
laugh
so oftentimes their arguments are not
really based in reality or reason it's
based in ad hominem and kind of an
emotional reaction are there no
legalities about recording people
without their consent i don't know how
the law works in america
in the united states in 38 states it's
perfectly legal so so long as one party
is consenting what does that mean it
means that you know that i'm speaking to
you
you are with the person that is
recording you and if you think about it
that makes sense it's common law
um in america um if you are with a
stranger and that stranger records you
without you knowing that they're
recording your conversation well we
would believe that the recording device
is an extension of the pencil and paper
in fact in courts courts have made the
argument that society would not consider
reasonable an expectation of privacy
which would render a less accurate
version of the events in question
uh you have more of a right there
upton sinclair who authored the jungle
ran back to his apartment and wrote down
what he saw
but a written rendition of facts is
oftentimes not as accurate as a
recording of those facts so as long as
one party is consenting in other words
if you and i are at a bar
and i'm talking to you and i'm recording
you and you don't know that i'm
recording you it's legal now there's 12
states where it's illegal
like for example california uh maryland
pennsylvania unless
someone nearby can overhear us
we no longer
if someone nearby is able to overhear
you then recording is permitted in
california we often do our journalism in
coffee shops
and in in some states like massachusetts
the law is so draconian or oregon so you
can't even do that we have challenged
the constitutionality of those laws
again we believe recording someone that
you're with is is a constitutional right
and again it's self-evident you can
write down what they say
no one's going to sue you for doing that
so we we've been very successful in
federal court in massachusetts we
overturned the law in massachusetts
project veritas did again another thing
that you did not know that's been edited
out of our wikipedia page we even
overturned the the law
on the grounds is unconstitutional
do you think do you struggle with it
ethically beyond the fact that there is
a legal precedent for you to be able to
record people if there are people around
to here or if one party is the one that
understands
do you feel like capturing somebody's
image their intonation the way that
they're talking about things when their
guard is down do you ever struggle with
that ethically
yes i mean this this book
we struggle more with the ethics of what
we do than anybody of course the
ra the rub on us is that were some
unethical scumbags who just go around
violating people's privacy but the
beauty and bane of ethics is that it's
inherently situational to quote jessica
midford who authored a book called the
uh
you know authored a book on muckraking
um and you know there's always
journalism is always going to harm
people information harms people
you know and the first amendment is the
first amendment to the bill of rights in
the constitution
um because all of the rights follow from
the first amendment so in a society that
places a primary value
on information that's unauthorized in
other words
i'm publishing information really
powerful people don't want published
you're going to harm people
good journalism harms people
um but that's the that's the really the
what makes us american i think the the
values
codified in the bill of rights and uh in
terms of deception um on a hidden camera
is not a form of deception it's not a
form of eavesdropping because the person
knows they're being interviewed and it's
not a form of entrapment you have to go
into this realm of undercover work to
get to this whole idea of deception
and there's a whole chapter in this book
called deception i present the paradox
of relative deception which means
you have two choices you can deceive the
audience or you can deceive your subject
and you're going to do one of these two
things
and i would prefer to deceive my subject
such that i can tell the truth to my
audience
sorry james that only presumes that the
subject that you are speaking to would
speak untruths if they knew that they
were being recorded there is a situation
in which you could speak to somebody
right now mean you're having a
conversation i'm not trying to deceive
anybody neither are you so there is a
possibility that you can do the
recording without deception happening to
either party
this is correct and
and this is what i talked about with
eric weinstein but
that presupposes that the person is
going to be more honest on the record
and i think it's a pretty fair
assumption that we were talking about
like pfizer pharmaceutical and the
department of justice and the pentagon
that these people are yes i'm a
journalist please tell me about all the
fraud you're committing
i think it's a pretty safe assumption
that people in the pentagon are not
going to be honest to a self-identified
report of the new york times and and in
this chapter called deception i talk
about this i say you know you know that
the leak leaks right
uh someone in the near new york times
gets leaked documents
well oftentimes the leaks
usually it's not in the form of
documents actually it's the form of an
authorized statement from a two-star
general it's really a form of deception
because the person in power is usually
manipulating the journalist
and usually those leaks are authorized
leaks the information is is given to the
journalists consensually
so we want to do these things
non-consensually we want to do these
things without the permission from those
in power which does involve deception
towards the source not the audience
speaking of leaks how much of the recent
aggression from the corporate press and
social media companies do you think is
downstream from wikileaks and edward
snowden is everyone in power terrified
of another huge scandal like that
i think that people yes
i think that people in power are more
terrified of us than we are of them and
i think that's a recent phenomenon but i
think with ed snowden
what what strikes me about that kate i'm
not ed snowden julian assange
is the indictment in virginia
which i read and what struck me about
that indictment was the statement i
think in the indictment said uh julian
assange had
had um prodded was it was it bradley
manning manning and said curious eyes
don't run dry
so this whole idea that assange was
involved in the hacking he was involved
now i don't know whether he was if he
did indeed hack the the databases well
that's a felony you can't do that but if
he merely prodded his source
to give him more information well that's
as american as apple pie
and journalists do that all the time
but i think that they're afraid yes and
ed snowden really kicked off that
revolution and julian assange kicked off
that revolution but now there's a whole
army of whistleblowers inside the
government
that are
trying to follow their conscience and
try to release information we just had a
story ten days ago inside the department
of defense a a marine corps darpa fellow
that authored this memorandum that
called anthony fauci a liar this was a
defense department document that was
buried on a top secret share drive much
similar to the
assange situation and this document was
given to project veritas and
authenticated by dr anthony fauci there
are a lot more people inside the
government that want to come forward
they're just afraid to be prosecuted the
way that um manning was was it a
surprise to be addressed by fouchy by
name
um
there were there were cheers in the
project veritas newsroom newsroom being
an suv that we were all inside of when
we were driving around that day
on an undisclosed location
um i think that uh i think that fouchy
again i think that faux fears us more
than we fear
we fear him and the marine corps major
was not the source of those documents
the guy who authored the uh
the guy at darpa inside the defense
department but to my shock
we reached out to joe murphy the marine
corps major
and he told us i'm paraphrasing him here
that there's a lot of good people inside
the government trying to do the right
thing trying to reform it from within i
think the marine corps in particular the
military take an oath you're not really
going to find
military guys you know marines blow the
whistle against their beloved core
and i think there's really kind of
it seems to me that they're stuck in
this dichotomy where they're trying to
reform it from within and it's hard to
do that
but
you know this guy told us that there's
other people out there that have
information and they need to release it
and i think they will
one of the criticisms that sometimes get
put forward is that the people who are
leaking documents or perhaps that are
being caught on film they're not
specialists and even if they have some
specialities they're maybe not the ones
that are at the pinnacle of whatever
triangle or hierarchy it is this marine
corps
guy i'm not sure if he's a specialist in
bioengineered weapons in vaccines in
mandates in public policy and the same
thing for the guy from pfizer i'm not
sure how high up the dude that you
caught on tape saying that natural
immunity is better than vaccine
the protection you get from vaccines
is there a
is there a temptation to overblow
the impact of a particular individual
who you can say
pfizer worker or marine corps general
you must have to think well look how
much does this person actually know
could be very easy to overblow their
credentials and just to make it seem
like a bigger deal than it is how do you
how do you find that balance well
ultimately accuracy is journalism's
primary objective and that's what makes
journalism different than other forms of
medium like propaganda or hollywood
films accuracy is the most important
thing so the question is is it true
you could so let me give you a
pattern to
run anathema to what you just said
if the cleaning lady
unearths the document in the pentagon
what matters is if the document is true
if if if a squirrel
with its mouth takes the document and
brings it to me it doesn't matter what
matters is whether it's true and i will
point you you brought up pfizer melissa
was a whistleblower she was a low-level
person in kansas or someplace like that
she had a relatively menial job i would
say
but she got access to the vice of the
senior director's emails
she got that because she was an employee
at the firm and she was able to get the
documents and the documents were indeed
true
the senior what do you mean what do you
mean when you say true
the dot the emails authored by vanessa
gellman who is a senior director at
pfizer said i'm paraphrasing guys i
don't have them in front of me
that we used fetal cells in the
development of the vaccine and we don't
want the consumer to know that so the
statement by the senior director quote
we don't want
the the people to know that the consumer
to know that that's a true state that's
she did indeed make that statement and
and it is newsworthy and it was brought
to us by a low-level person who had
access to high-level information the
marine corps major who wrote the
documents fair enough some people have
questioned his credibility dr fauci
questioned his credibility but
the the department of defense document
clearly stipulates that eco health
alliance approached uh this firm equal
health alliance to approach darpa with
gain of function research and it was
rejected the question is is that true
that's all that matters
whoever made the allegation now i i'm
calling on anthony anthony fauci to
release information to the contrary
because this marine corps major also
stated in the department of defense
document that anthony fauci was
approached by equal health alliance
under niad and proceeded so journalism's
objective is to get is to is to try to
use however many sources you need to use
to corroborate the information and by
the way let me just add
the paragon of investigative journals in
these days the new york times is they
don't show you any documents the trump
tax return story not one document not
one on the record source they just ask
us to trust them by virtue of the fact
they think they can be trusted by the
decree they are indeed credible well
that's a self-anointed racket i don't
ask you to trust me
i ask you to trust the evidence of your
own eyes and ears
i don't think that very many people do
trust those mainstream media
organizations anymore i've never seen
people who the uk isn't massively
conspiratorial right
the us leads the
charge when it comes to that and
the people in the uk are not
yet i see so much skepticism around what
we see in the media on a day-to-day
basis from people that are british
for that to have pushed people that are
from this country to that degree and
then when i see the stuff coming across
from america
it seems to me like mainstream media has
never been
in as bad of a situation as this even if
you were to look at vietnam you know the
the situation around vietnam bring our
boys home and people are i know that
that's more against the government but
still it's a situation where i don't
know
is this
are they redeemable a mainstream media
ever redeemable from this situation
i think you bring up a very astute point
which i haven't heard articulated which
is i think you're right i think i don't
i'm not a pollster but
just using my intuition i think i think
the majority of people don't trust the
media
actually i think some polls have
indicated that they have a lower
approval than congress
but but what i write about in this book
is it's about fear what do i mean by
this this is this is a this is the most
important point of the whole book
in communist countries 98
of people did not want the communist
outcome but were too afraid to push back
against the two percent of the crazy
for fear i don't know if you're they're
gonna lose their you know whatever they
have they're they're afraid to lose
something and i see it in my own life
with people that i know
that they know it's all a lie
but they're not going to push back
against it let me give you a less
abstract example
people that complain about the
censorship and complain about the lies
many of these people are unwilling to
lose your twitter accounts you know who
you are
you'll hesitate to speak the truth
unspoken for fear that jack dorsey will
ban you or instagram will take away your
account and we wouldn't want our
instagram taken away would we we
wouldn't want our twitter account taken
away would we that's a very slippery
slope you're trying to climb
and i quote this guy sultan eats in this
book so many times people say what does
sultanism have to do with it well
sulzanison says
you when you start to survive at any
price
when you start to sacrifice your
principles and your integrity
um to maintain what is yours
there's a hundred and twenty thousand
people working for the department of
justice i don't think they're all bad
people if you polled them secretly i
think the majority of them thought it
was
horrible what happened to me
but how many of those people have the
stones to blow the whistle on the
department of justice can you find me
one fbi agent who's willing to speak up
publicly
of course not that person might be
prosecuted that person might go to jail
might be incarcerated and if nothing
else they might lose their pension and
we wouldn't want to lose our pension
would we
so i think you i think it's you're right
that people
don't trust cnn and don't like the
censorship but i think there's a fear
and a hesitation
to do the right thing for fear of being
branded with that scarlet letter for
fear of being defamed and disliked by
all the people who have the power to
brand you well the problem is you kind
of have a tragedy of the commons thing
going on one person's sacrifice you know
one person goes to jail in order to tell
everybody else about the lies but nobody
else has to go to jail but everybody
else gets to benefit from the expose
about whatever it is so there's always
this asymmetry of benefit and cost one
person or a small number of people are
always going to bet all of the cost or
the vast majority of the cost and then
everybody else gets to benefit from the
release of information so you know from
a personal situation i see why people
would be scared by this
i think though people what's changed
since 2013 when ed snowden did that and
ed snowden is the perfect
personification of what you speak of
we would not know about the fourth
amendment violations is that what's
changed and i've seen it in my own life
and i write a chapter called insiders
is that their people place more in the
variable of the equation they place so
much more emphasis on politics these
days than they did five years ago
because it's affecting it's affecting
everyone's children with the vaccine for
example it's affecting where people want
to live
um that more people place more value on
following their conscience than ever
before in american history and more
people are placing more they'll say i'll
give it all up for the public's right to
know we've seen this in my life with the
for example eric cochran who blew the
whistle on pinterest two years ago he
was the first real whistleblower i've
worked with he was making a ton of money
working for a 15 billion dollar company
and he released
documents showing that pinterest was
censoring bible verses now you would
have thought he was a crackpot you would
have thought i was a conspiracy theorist
he had the code you couldn't type in a
christian bible verse on pinterest it
would change it to verses like a boxing
match not verse not the bible verses
and and and when he did it he inspired
carrie porch of cnn and what happens is
a sort of courage
uh contagious domino effect pages
epidemic domino effect
and and i think you need to keep that
veritas intends to release a story on
wednesday of this week featuring someone
in the medical field
showing um we'll break a little news on
your program here um and i won't say
specifically what
but children in the vaccine and this
story is going to outrage pros
pro-vaccine people as much as it will
outrage anti-vax people and this woman
that came to me was so scared
but
same theme every single time they they
thought that people had a right to know
and they thought that people's right to
know exceeded their own value on their
own personal welfare so i think you're
going to see this happen more often than
it did 10 years ago with ed snowden and
julian assange i want to get into some
of the um ethical difficulties that you
have internally within project veritas
i'm fascinated by this i'm fascinated by
the fact that there must be a constant
balancing act around what do we choose
to publish what do we choose not to have
we met legal limits there must be some
degree of scrutiny and whatever advice
you get from your lawyers but then
there's another step as well so one of
the things that i considered is that as
you
gain more and more popularity and your
platform continues to grow
how do you avoid the risk of people who
want to give you information simply to
be associated with project veritas how
do you ensure that your whistleblowers
are legit
well that goes back to that
corroboration that goes back to for
example the story i'm just sort of
teasing our video
on wednesday of this week where um
the insider
works for the company we ask to see
their driver's license you know we
interview them um
there are recordings they provide
um i don't ask you to trust me or i've
interviewed this source she can say
whatever she wants but there's
recordings of the thing actually
happening okay then you say well is that
a deep fake video maybe those are fake
videos so you go talk to the people in
the video and they are indeed real
people and they they admit they were
recorded
so you do what you have to do there's no
um
there's no rule that says you must
interview five sources to confirm that
you do whatever you have to do
and i think the evidence behind people
say well james o'keefe you're a
right-wing extremist well guess what if
i was a right-wing extremist i would
have published ashley biden's diary
and there were people in my life that
said well you should do that and and
they have a right to say that maybe they
want to hurt joe biden but my job is not
to hurt joe biden i felt like the stuff
in that diary even if it were real which
i was i was 99
certain the diary was real i wasn't 100
could have been a setup
i felt that i should not see
the the private musings this woman who i
don't know maybe she was on drugs or she
was writing poetry in her diary i don't
know
i felt there are certain things the
public shouldn't see
and i wrestled with this question and i
actually wrote an email to my staff
which is an exhibit in federal court
before the prosecutors and it was this
exhibit was presented before the federal
judge and i'm going to read it to you i
wrote this to my staff i quoted ernest
hemingway
and i was thinking about what is ethics
because of course ethics is subjective
ethics depends upon what value you
placed on the information the people who
hate joe biden they release any
information i wrote this i said ernest
hemingway said i know only that what is
moral is what you feel good after and
what is immoral is what you feel bad
after
and when it comes to journalism
it's rarely what you feel good about
afterward it is only that which makes
you feel better
than you would otherwise
and i just felt like publishing this
woman's diary
i just there's something wrong about it
i don't think public eye should see it
using undercover techniques recording
people catching people doing bad things
you can't justify the ethics of this in
the abstract it's like trying to say
that you know uh
you know
water is dry and coal is fireproof
deception in any way matter shape or
form is is a kind of wrong
but you have to do it sometimes for the
greater cause to show people the truth
so i think um we struggle with ethics we
i've written a whole book about it
honestly that's what this book is about
where are the boundaries the boundaries
are inherently subjective and inherently
situational and increasingly people are
more divided than ever on what should be
exposed
would you say that veritas is
politically impartial
well that's a pretty
existential question
in a day and age when
we are divided on facts
i think the media is monolithic
um
the i would to quote my late and mentor
andrew breitbart i do believe the media
is part of the democratic democrat party
national complex democratic party
complex so people will come to me with
information that is anathema to what is
presented on tv and that's traditionally
been things that
are for example would expose democrats
lying since
cnn and the new york times and the
washington post are aligned with
political interests but i think
increasingly
that's going to be less the case less of
the case for example we did a story on
alex stovall who is a republican in
arizona
and i don't know if you saw this video
but he's a conservative republican guy
running in the primary in in the state
of arizona as a congressman and he said
some things in his vehicle privately
that contradicted what he said publicly
so publicly he says yes we need to audit
that election and then privately he said
to his colleague who is a whistleblower
and his campaign oh i don't think there
was enough fraud to overturn the
election i don't think he said anything
wrong i i happen to agree with alex
stovall it doesn't seem to be enough
voter fraud to overturn the election but
it was his lack of courage to say these
things publicly and i think over time
you're going to see that asymptote of of
uh of of uh party stories approach
closer to 50
but it will never be half and half
so long as you have all the organs of
dissemination in this country completely
aligned with one political party most
whistleblowers are going to be exposing
the democratic party since that's the
message that we get from tech and and uh
the mainstream media how many tips do
you get per day you got any idea
um hundreds
hundreds
yeah we haven't we i call the um
not the help line but i i i tell my
staff we we call the hope line
most of these people are hopeless and
cynical and
want something to believe in and and uh
they reach out to us and uh
increasingly i the the thing we hear
from people is there really isn't
anywhere else for them to go they
certainly can't go to the uh
the new york times they'd probably
either ignore them or uh
burn their cover
you put out a video the other day saying
i am not suicidal
how concerned are you for your personal
safety
well i think that's another existential
question the first page of this book
addresses this question people say do
you fear for your life and
it doesn't matter how i answer that in
the negative or affirmative either i
will sound prideful or self-angrizing or
naive
if i say i fear for my life you'll think
i'm full of myself if i say i don't
you'll think i might i'm naive so i
don't know how to and that was that
video was my form of answering that
question i was like you half the
comments are you afraid first of all no
i'm not afraid for my life if i was
afraid for my life i sure as [ __ ]
wouldn't have started project veritas
um
i
i did not realize how serious this was
until
april of this year when i was banned
from twitter what was the story though
that was the day if there was one moment
in time it wasn't my incarceration it
wasn't my
you know it was that day when they
banned me
from twitter for quoting
cnn charlie chester saying that we're
propaganda and twitter that's when i
realized
whoa
that was my
why what ill black pill red pill uphill
down pill i don't know what that you
know what but the metaphor but
because i had quoted the control room
director at cnn
saying
what we all suspect
and they banned me for it i i never
thought we'd cross that rubicon of
course they made up some i don't know
some some weird excuse like i'd created
fake accounts on twitter which is so
defamatory we sued them for defamation
and that that matters ongoing but
for me it was like i guess there is an
innocence there is an idealism
there is a hope
here that i feel internally and my
colleagues feel there's a way the world
ought to be
and we don't ascribe to the cynicism for
me it was like oh they're not going to
ban me for that i'm just reporting on
what this guy's saying and they didn't
ban him by the way i'm quoting this guy
they should be banning the guy i'm
quoting not me
so for me it was like oh
okay
now things are about to get real
and that's when i sort of woke up from
my idealism just a little bit i'm still
very idealistic and then the fbi raids
that was then it got to defcon one it
was like okay now they're now they're
raiding my home and taking my [ __ ] and
putting a journalist in handcuffs again
i didn't think that would happen
i i don't want to live in a world where
that can happen i reject the premise
that i do live in that world
so that that so that i put the video out
you speak of because half the comments
say i should fear for my life and i said
well i'm not suicidal i love my life i'm
blessed to do what i do and um it's all
going to be okay
how often do you spend or how long
typically during a day do you spend
talking to legal counsel
oh
constantly
is it just a guy that's
like on your right shoulder for the
entirety of the day something comes up
you ask john a question john tells you
the answer
something to that effect it's something
we have many lawyers some of them are in
house many of them are out of house i
could effectively pass the bar exam at
this point
i myself went to law school for a year
dropped out
um been deposed many times been to court
many times we've never lost a case
everything we do is run by lawyers you
have issues of consent you have issues
of privacy tortious interference
um you have non-disclosure agreements um
we we this case nikki v vapor i
effectively have the whole thing
memorized it's just
the thing about law is
that we live in a nation of laws and one
of the great things about the united
states of america
in the american founding is this idea
that we are equal we are all created
equal what does that mean
well it does not mean that i run as fast
as you or i cook as good as you it means
we're equal before the law this this is
a beautiful thing in the courts
some of the most amazing moments of my
life have been winning in court there
was a moment in the shirley teeter case
where it went to jury verdict
and when when people make these sort of
irrational rhetorical arguments you see
on cable news all that stuff melts away
in court that doesn't matter anymore
it's all about logic
and and truth
and you get to the point in the in the
in the lawsuit when the judge is like
where's the edit counselor
well he mixed this moment over here and
he said yeah but but that's what
journalists do they tell stories and
that's what o'keefe was supposed to do
but o'keefe did not opine on scott
foval's statements and the judge goes
why would question the ethics of james
o'keefe if he did opine on scott phill
and it was so beautiful because every
now and then
once in a while
when you're in court you actually see
the administration of justice it's very
rare
but it does happen
in that case we hired a lawyer who
happens to be blind
the woman who sued me her name was
shirley teeter she was a disabled woman
she had copd she had an oxygen tank
undoubtedly to engender sympathy with
the jury
so we had some tricks up our sleeve we
brought a lawyer in court who was
literally blind and he had a cane and
you know he listened to the uh
transcripts through his headphones
i could tell you story after story about
litigation and about the law but um
clearly it surrounds us always we follow
the law we never break the law
and um we are we are a proponents and
adherence to the first amendment
as the scrutiny increases with project
veritas the
fallout if you guys were rumbled to have
broken the law or to have stepped across
the line that's going to become
increasingly tight right there's going
to be more eyes more scrutiny is this
something that you're conscious of is
this something where you think
as you continue to grow the platform
there's
more restrictions it's more laborious
more effortful to get yourself to the
stage where you can release things is
this something that you
attention that you feel
it's my cross to bear is how i put it i
tell my staff that we have we have an
ethics policy at veritas and the here's
the most important ethical guideline
always behave like there's a jury in the
room watching everything you do and say
even when you're alone
and people say i don't want to live in
that world and i say that is the world
that we live in
so as long as you behave like a jury is
always watching like you're in a
goldfish bowl
then you're okay
now what's terrifying is when they
falsely accuse you which is what the
feds did in the ashley biden case that
they had they had i guess insinuated
that i was involved in the theft
i wasn't i wasn't even aware the thing
was stolen even if it was stolen
i would be protected by the united
states supreme court to receive and or
publish the document i didn't
but yeah i think your question
you have to behave like you're always
being watched there's a chapter in this
book called secrecy and i again it took
me many years to learn this lesson many
years
i've seen people try to keep secrets you
can never keep a secret in this business
you that we have we have you understand
we have like
two national secu uh two pulitzer
prize-winning national security
reporters the new york times who spend
most of their time investigating me
that's not an exaggeration adam goldman
and mike schmidt at the new york times
are not investigating the fda or the
pentagon or i don't know
stuff happening in ukraine
they're literally staked out of my
sources houses
this is a true story they're literally
surveilling my sources trying to dox my
sources they think that james o'keefe
and project veritas is what we need to
investigate so any secret i've ever had
has been unearthed
and if you don't believe me believe that
i've been to court a dozen times won
every case been deposed and they got
nothing on me they got nothing
and if they had something wouldn't you
know about it
so
i i that's my cross to bear the one area
in life where i i think you can keep
secrets
is your sexual life i think we should
avoid that area i think we should stay
out of people's bedrooms
the exception being if you're doing
something to a minor
we did a story on cnn's rick saleeby he
was soliciting pictures of a 15 year old
you can't do that that's against the law
as long as you don't break the law i
think we stay out of people's bedrooms
wasn't jake tapas producer doing
something dodgy as well
that was the individual i just spoke
rick saleem he worked for jake tap
rick saleem was a second guy after the
the first guy in connecticut um this was
a whistleblower who was a prostitute who
came to project veritas and to your
point you said well you know chris why
would we trust prostitutes well we we
interviewed her former prostitute
and uh this woman uh had audio facetime
calls
and we corroborated those turns out they
were real
and in the in these facetime calls rick
saleeby was was uh soliciting pictures
of a 15 year old girl
sexual fantasies about his fiancee's
underage daughter really disturbing
stuff
and we thought that the interests of the
14 year old and 15 year old girls he
spoke of were paramount because he was
going to be living with this 14 year old
girl so we we we blurred the man's face
we did the ethical thing
um we went straight to the fiance
she did not like project veritas at
first but then thanked us the police got
involved cnn
uh fired or he resigned
quietly by the way they didn't want to
say anything at that jeff sucker's
network and that's what happened there
james o'keefe ladies and gentlemen
american muckraker people can get that
on amazon for it'll be out it'll be out
by the time this is out
yes where else can people go to keep up
to date with what you do well all
proceeds from this book go to um our
nonprofit project veritas american
americanmuckraker.com you go to amazon
it's top 10 on amazon right now and and
we're an organization we're a charitable
non-profit news organization we're very
independent so we encourage people to
have an open mind and to learn how to do
journalism
in clown world where truth is upside
down and two plus two equals five
support our work buy the book uh send us
a tip at
veritastipsprotonmail.com if you're
there in the united kingdom or anywhere
you are worldwide and you wanna speak
the truth unspoken uh buy this book and
read about how to do it stay safe mate
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace